This episode is brought to you by Ridge wallet,
Crack Michael here, still in the same room in the same house.
I haven't really left since March and I'm recording another video all alone in
this room in front of the same. God.
Sorry about that folks.
Now I'm very eager to grab a drink with friends without the specter of death
haunting me. And I'm sure you are too. As citizens crave,
basic social interaction and the economy craves our spending technologies and
policies designed to prevent the spread of coronavirus are popping up everywhere
from boring, but well-established proven methods like washing social distancing,
and wearing a mask over your mouth and nose to newer approaches like
smartphone-based GPS tracing and thermal imaging cameras.
Repurposed to check for fevers,
governments and businesses are ready to try anything that will get our terrified
asses off the couch and into the nation's cubicles and inexplicably sticky diner
routes. Now,
while we are 100% ready to luxuriate in the taco bell dining experience,
we wouldn't be wisecrack. If we didn't ask the tough questions,
like to what extent our newer policies surrounding COVID 19,
keeping us safe from infection and still harder to think about.
Are they even supposed to welcome to this wisecrack addition on security
theater? But before we continue, I want to give a shout out to this week.
Sponsor Ridge wallet.
The Ridge wallet is a light sleek and industrial wallet designed to last you a
lifetime. Each wallet is made with RFID blocking technology,
which protects you from digital pickpockets.
The durable metal also means each wallet comes with a lifetime warranty.
So this could be the last wallet you ever buy. It's perfect.
If you don't want to carry around a bulky old leather lump in your pocket,
but still want to maximize the amount of cards you carry.
It holds up to 12 cards and still has room for cash.
The rich team is so confident that you will like it,
that if you don't and send it back within 45 days,
you will receive a full refund. Grab your own word wallet today,
by going to rich.com/wisecrack and use promo code wisecrack to get 10% off,
you will get free worldwide shipping and return.
So click the link in the description to get one today. Now back to the show,
to be clear, we're not here to peddle conspiracy theory,
mask and social distancing work to dramatically reduce the spread of COVID-19
cover your nose kids.
But as we're about to find out whether you're trying to manage viruses or
terrorism,
there's more to this seemingly basic concept of security than you might expect.
If you're in a state that has tried reopening restaurants and bars,
or even if you hopped on a plane,
you might have encountered new procedures meant to make us feel safe.
These range from restaurants and bars operating at diminished capacity to States
like New York only allowing outdoor dining to businesses,
touting extra cleaning procedures to buildings in some airports,
testing out using thermal scanners to identify people running potentially COVID
induced fevers, but not all strategies are equal.
Some are questionably effective at best and potentially harmful at worst as
Evan Selinger and Brenda Lee young put it in a recent article,
installing thermal scanning as part of a back to work process might create a
false sense of security that convinces some to prematurely return to their jobs
and emboldens others to relax more effective strategies such as social
distancing and responsible contact tracing efforts.
A quick definition contact tracing is the practice of tracking down people who
were exposed to another sick person in order to proactively treat or isolate
them and contain the spread of the disease,
selling her and Leon claim that thermal scanning and other fancy looking quick
fixes are not true security. Rather, there were privacy expert.
Bruce Schneier has famously called security theatre or security measures that
make people feel more secure without doing anything,
to actually improve their security.
Think for instance of the little yard signs that security companies planted
front lawns to let passers by know that the designated house is protected by an
alarm. Now,
seeing that placard as you come home everyday may help you sleep better at
night, which is arguably a good thing in and of itself.
But it's important to remember that the sign itself can not actually detect or
prevent a break-in or slow it down.
Once it has started when an angry bowel rod comes to steal your PlayStation,
that little piece of metal on a stick is not going to pull a Gandalf.
So you and your uninsured gadgets can escape out the back door.
Maybe the one.
Deters people,
or maybe you just advertises to thieves that they need to be extra careful when
robbing you as convenient as technologies like remote temperature taking in
real-time phone enabled contact tracing would be selling during Leon point out
that so far, they just don't cut the proverbial mustard.
Silicon Valley loves to tote glitzy new GPS,
backed ways to track the spread of disease, but as reported in wired,
many health officials don't consider contact tracing programs that use
smartphone location data to be as effective as traditional human based contact
tracing programs.
Then there's temperature checks and the thermal imaging airline's pushed in may
for temperature checks at airports. Dr. Martin said Tron,
the CDC director of global mitigation and quarantine called the idea a poorly
designed control and detection strategy and an earlier screening by the CDC of
over 30,000 passengers did not catch a single COVID-19 case,
even though some of the same passengers later tested positive for the virus and
per the Washington post thermal imaging cameras have not demonstrated the
ability to detect internal body temperature with the accuracy of more basic
thermometers. In other words,
organizations around the country are spending a lot of money to install
technologies that apparently do not work for their stated purposes of protecting
people from infection. But why, while in casual conversation,
we might understand the word security to mean the process of keeping people
safe.
Schneider contends in his book beyond fear thinking sensibly about security in
an uncertain world that it's not nearly that straightforward. According to him,
what we call security is actually a complex interplay between the different
agendas of the various individuals and organizations invested in a given
situation. What he calls the players,
a given security policy emerges out of the negotiations between these players
influenced by the relative levels of power between them resulting in a program
that serves the interest, the most powerful players first and foremost,
and may or may not actually increase safety for end-users as an almost secondary
goal as sample Schneier sites.
The fact that in the immediate aftermath of nine 11 tweezers,
a nail files were banned on planes while some actually combustible materials
lighters were allowed through this.
According to Schneider was the result of the relative influence of the tobacco
lobby on the government's decision making process.
One player pressuring another big tweezer.
Unfortunately didn't have the cloud to stay off the TSH security
theater happens when the more powerful players involved are focused on their own
self-interest to the detriment of the holistic security of the system they
participate in from these circumstances.
Policies can emerge that create the appearance of doing something without
actually making people safer.
Still players can find such systems very attractive Schneier claims
offering security theater can improve market share just as much as offering
actual security. And it is significantly cheaper to provide.
He also notes that most people are comforted by action, whether good or bad.
The most infamous example of such a system is again,
the post nine 11 airport security system and the wake of the attacks.
The most powerful players involved had an overriding political and economic
agenda to get people flying again, as soon as possible,
which meant that they had to make the average citizen feel safe enough to do so.
The resulting air force security theater satisfied the government's need to
implement a public facing response to terror,
as well as the airlines need for your sweaty pocket cash. In other words,
set system provides the biggest players with what they want while not
necessarily making flying significantly safer to put it bluntly.
From this point of view, the federal government employees,
many thousands of TSA agents and purchases,
an equal number of hideous blue shirt and black pants combos to make the average
citizen feel safe enough to fly,
even though the process of taking off your shoes down in your entire water
bottle and one ill swag,
and having a tired middle-aged man examine your junk via a body scanner,
probably doesn't make you that much safer consider friends since the fact that
in one nationwide test of the system conducted by Homeland security in 2015,
undercover agents were able to smuggle mock explosives and weapons through
security checkpoints, a whopping 95% of the time.
And you thought your last annual review in bed, unfortunately,
many of the criticisms applied to our handling of airport security can be
applied to some though not all of our society's current attempts to address the
problem of coronavirus building off of Schneider's framework law professor and
privacy expert.
Peter Swire has gone so far as to claim that we may be facing a kind of public
health theatre on par with the security theater installed in the wake of nine
11, citing the temptation for government agencies to resort to unreliable phone
location tracking is the lazy man's approach to contact tracing Swire claims
that government officials had great incentives to show the public.
They are doing something, anything to address the crisis. However,
his swear goes on to note that absent and empirical showing accuracy and
actionability that does not exist to date calls for such location tracking quite
possibly our security theater rather than actual security.
This description ties in neatly with Snyder's framework and our current moment,
the players involved in formulating our collective policy for handling
coronavirus include governments at the national state and local levels and
businesses ranging in size from giant corporations to your local pizza joint.
These players who have varying levels of power bring to the table,
many different agendas in the case of governments to be seen taking action
effective or not, and to safeguard a struggling economy.
And in the case of businesses to attract enough customers to turn a profit or at
least keep operations going,
perhaps there is no better example of health security theater than the quickly
maligned reopening plans of AMC theaters for July as the LA times noted the
challenge is not just reopening.
It's getting people comfortable enough to show up.
So the company sought to assuage fears by reducing capacity and spending
millions of dollars on sanitation equipment.
While all of those things can reduce the spread of the virus,
the policy that is most effective at keeping people safe, wasn't.
On the docket wearing masks.
While the company would require employees to wear them,
it would not universally required patrons to that was deemed political,
which is a nice way of saying not good for business.
Although the company reversed course after backlash and stated they would
require masks. If I can make a somewhat unscientific analogy,
the sanitation equipment is like that dude,
at the frat party who wanted to write a razor scooter off of a roof telling you
chill, bro, I'll wear a helmet.
And here our imaginary bro reveals a basic danger of security theater,
half measures that make you feel safer about doing something incredibly dumb.
Importantly,
we're not here to malign safety measures like wearing helmets or doing
temperature checks.
These things are fine so long as they don't give people a false sense of
security as they careen headfirst into a traumatic brain injury or so long as
they don't pull money and other resources from more impactful safety measures.
After all,
you don't want to spend all your money on seatbelts for a car known to burst
into flames. Now AMSE scrapped mask.
Policy is not unique as restaurants and bars,
tout menu cleaning and waiters clad,
and PPE many are not requiring patrons to wear masks as they amble past other
diners, to be fair, some businesses are just trying to do the right thing,
keeping their employees and customers safe while trying to limit layoffs.
But as Schneier observed in the wake of nine 11 self-interest is a powerful
force. Even in the midst of a national emergency.
If the best science says that the best way to stay safe is to stay home and to
avoid the cheesecake factory. Quite literally like the plague,
it is in the restaurant.
Player's best interest to ignore that data as much as possible. Instead,
they might implement relatively less costly security theater measures that give
people enough confidence to drown their sorrows and avocado egg rolls jokes
aside their recent tragic spikes and infection rates in Texas, Florida,
and California demonstrate how security theater can create a gap between the
perception of safety and an unsafe reality at its best security theater can be a
useful part of a functioning society,
deterring lesser threats while providing us some day to day peace of mind.
And it's worse though, as a by-product of big players,
desire for a Swift return to normalcy,
it can encourage average people to lower their defenses before it's really safe
to do so with devastating consequences.
But what do you think wisecrack or some of the safety measures that we see just
for show or is everyone just scrambling to do the right thing?
Let us know in the comments and be sure to subscribe and ring that bell big,
thanks to our patrons for supporting our podcast and the channel and as always,
thanks for watching later.
[Inaudible].